[Music]
I would like to say that with two
exceptions we have been so thoroughly
disappointed and rejected by all the
elected officials in New York City with
two outstanding exceptions one of them
is here with us today New York city
councilman from Queens Dan howerin I
want to thank you for your stand as
being the only city councilman in New
York City to stand up for the
sensitivities of the
families uh I think Daniel because he
was the only politician New York city
councilman if you can give us some brief
remarks um and I saw you at the Walmart
hearing you were
brilliant I mean talk about a den of
cavemen
um oh my God what
neand let me first apologize on behalf
of the cowards in politics who choose to
hide behind special interests instead of
standing up for what is right um I have
the dubious distinction of having been
slimed by the New York Times in a front
page article because I dared to point
out that certain members of the uniform
sanitation service slowed down the snow
response that was
me um I guess I have to make a
confession very
easy one of them uh although I never
mentioned it once in my campaign my
cousin Lieutenant Vincent howerin was a
firefighter who went up into the towers
never to come down he left a wife and
six kids ranging in age from
three until
18 and his wife Marie carries on like
the good Irish Catholic that she is um
one of 48 first cousins 162 second
cousins we are the typical Irish family
in New York the howerin have been there
for five generations my father served as
a Deputy Commissioner
my grandfather a homicide Lieutenant my
great-grandfather a chief of
police people ask me constantly why why
why a conservative libertarian
Republican would stay in New York
City and I'm beginning to ask myself
that
question I do that because of men like
those who fell in the towers like the
dozens of my family who have served this
city year after year thanklessly my my
brother Patrick now a lieutenant in the
fire department went up into the towers
he came out my brother
Terren was not out of the academy yet so
in case you hadn't noticed my family
spends a bit of time serving the city of
New York I left the police department to
go to law school became a prosecutor and
a defense attorney and for some
ridiculous reason in 2009 ran for office
I was told I would never win in a 3:1
Democrat to Republican District
we won we won because Americans have
values the other important reason why no
one stands up for the mosque
situation in addition to the special
interests and we all know what they are
is because Americans are quick to forget
their own
history in 2009 I stood with only two
other council members at the 9/11
Memorial ceremony the speaker of the
city council who is running for mayor
and of course the council member whose
District it was in missing were the
other 48 members of the New York City
Council I'm sure they'll all be there
next year because it's a 10-y year
anniversary but you have to ask yourself
if politicians are willing able to take
families like this and say to them we
don't care imagine what they are going
to do to the government they run would
World War II veterans stand for a Shinto
Temple to be built on the Arizona
Memorial absolutely not the greatest
Generation would never stand for
something like that and has nothing to
do with tolerance in fact if you
remember just a few years before the 911
attacks we heard about Danish
cartoonists who had
problems jihads and fatwas declared
because of political
cartoons political
cartoons and in a fit of PC many in the
United States including the liberal
press
condemned those journalists who
supported the First
Amendment how ironic that they can now
tell us
that we have no right to the indignity
of 41 dead First Responders and 4,000
Americans who perished simply because
they got up and went to work on
September 11th
2001 I would just like to say that
throughout this
country we are facing a crisis of
conscience politicians make mistakes I'm
far from perfect I know in the coming
weeks I will be attacked again and again
because I supported Walmart's right to
come to New York City that I exposed a
fake study that Chicago
did I know I'll get attacked because at
the end of the day I've stood up for 911
families who spoke out against the
mosque so of course I'm a racist I'm an
islamophobe I'm a bigot despite the fact
that I'm no longer a Christian and I am
in a very minority religion but that's
okay because once again the media is
going to tell you exactly what you need
to think I'll also of course get
attacked because I'm going to come after
the unions like the sanitation
workers and it's a shame because most of
those workers are hardworking
individuals but their Union leadership
has a different
design the 911 Cordoba initiative has
many flaws but let me just tell you the
one they don't want you talk about fact
been operating the last years without a
certificate of occupancy that the city
of New York has looked the other way to
building code violations failures to
meet the assembly requirements the fact
is that the city is complicit complicit
in what is happening there and if we
can't get our political leadership to do
it there's only one place we can turn we
the people have to be the moving Force
here the people have to say enough
I would like to thank Pamela for all
that she has done and I would like to
apologize again to these family members
I cannot pretend to know what it's like
to lose a son or a brother a cousin was
close enough but let me tell you there
are some of us who will never forget
that day and who will never give up even
the sinking ship of the city of New York
because if there's one good person left
the city should get spared I think
somebody said that once in history well
we'll try to find that one person in New
[Applause]
York we have to we have to learn from
our adversaries on the left they never
give up they lose they come back again
they lose they come back again they
never give up now there are no legal
hurdles in front of this mosque there
are no politicians with the notable
exception of the New York city
councilman right here and arario and a
few others who are on our side there is
nothing essentially stopping this mosque
from being built except that lovers of
Freedom are not going to let it happen
it ain't built yet it ain't
over
tenacity we have to never give up we
have to have tenacity and our next
speaker is one of the most remarkably
tenacious and courageous women I've ever
been privileged to know someone who was
at our June 6th Rally or September 11th
rally the Walmart protest everything
that she has every time she has a chance
to stand for Freedom she does we should
all imitate her we should all emulate
her and we should all applaud her and
Nelly brinsky
[Applause]